what do we know about life on Earth how
many species are we aware of a tenth of
them a hundredth perhaps what do we know
about the bonds that link them
the earth is a miracle life remains a
mystery
families of animals form united by
customs and rituals that are handed down
through the generations
some adapt to the nature of their
pasture and their pasture adapts to them
and both gain the animal Sates its
hunger and the tree can blossom again
in the great adventure of life on earth
every species has a role to play every
species has its place none is futile or
harmful
they all balance out
and that's where you homo sapiens why is
human enter the story
you benefit from a fabulous four billion
year old legacy bequeathed by the earth
you're only 200 thousand years old but
you have changed the face of the world
despite your vulnerability you have
taken possession of every habitat and
conquered swathes of territory like no
other species before you
after a hundred and eighty thousand
nomadic years and thanks to a more
Clement climate humans settle down they
no longer depended on hunting for
survival they chose to live in wet
environments that abounded in fish game
and wild plants there were land water
and life combined